hey this is kind of interesting over the
years we've been featured on Canadian
television around the gamergate days
we've been featured multiple times
coverage of Donald Trump on French
television programs and it came to my
attention that the David Pakman show has
been featured on Australian TV and it
was a story about a defense industry
minister named Christopher Pyne who is
fighting a controversy when his twitter
account was linked to a porn website and
in that story Australian TV include a
clip included a clip of my sort of
joking coverage of when Ted Cruz
favorited a porn video and I guess kind
of tried to say that he was hacked take
a look at this video from Australian
television very funny the lewd like
lasted four hours to Christopher Pyne
woke up I was hacked overnight
I was asleep at 2:00 a.m. it is feasible
that it was hacked it's also feasible
that he might have accidentally liked
something and forgot to unlike it
throughout just browsing away Twitter
users quickly ridiculed the hacking
claim similar to the response of former
US presidential candidate copped after
his Twitter account endorsed a sex video
someone took control of Ted Cruz's
account and did nothing other than like
a single porn video that's what you have
to believe the word hacking sits
uncomfortably alongside Christopher Pond
yeah sorta cool heard from a few
Australian viewers whose side and we're
linking to one of those French TV
stories in the description as well and I
think you hear you laughing in the
background on early in TV there was like
a little interjection I was about to say
something and I steamrolled right
through it it did feel big yeah alright
so Pat as well featured on Australian
television big big day at the David
Pakman show